essa sou eu na fala da minha casa com
menos de 2 anos de idade
esta é a maior referência registro de
tecnologia que eu tenho da minha
infância
esta tv ela serviu de fonte de
inspiração para que os meus pais
projetar sem o futuro dos seus dois
filhos
hoje a realidade é diferente
a tv ela não tenha tanta relevância como
tinha antes
ela é apenas mais um dos canais de
comunicação ligados à internet e os meus
pais nunca poderia imaginar tamanha
evolução porque porque para ele é
importante sonhar e saber como seria a
trajetória dos seus filhos na nossa
sociedade
o meu pai dizia para nós negro deve
andar arrumado e com documentos no bolso
caso seja parado na rua ea minha mãe ela
dizia
tem que estudar para se preparar para o
futuro
como se isso fosse só para negros não
eles diziam isto porque porque
imaginavam que negros com esses
atributos poderiam circular melhor nos
grupos brancos e sonhar com mais
oportunidades mas para mim não importava
a cor da minha pele
eu só queria sonhar e continua fazendo
isso o tempo todo mas a diferença é que
hoje eu me importo 5 mi acordo com a cor
da minha pele
por que por que humildemente eu possa
ser uma referência de futuro para outros
jovens que tiveram uma história similar
à minha
tive várias perdas ao longo do caminho
minha mãe alguns anos atrás sofreu um
acidente e foi atropelada na porta de
casa e ficou conosco mas com uma sequela
neurológica
meses depois o meu pai se foi com câncer
logo em seguida o meu irmão por
problemas psiquiátricos e como continuar
sonhando e perseguindo o futuro tão
falar
pelos meus pais por eles
meus pais que me deram a base de tudo o
que eu sou hoje e pela minha família que
me apoiou em todas as loucuras que o
invento até aceitar um convite para
falar no técnico e pela curiosidade que
me move desde criança e esta curiosidade
levou aquela menina da tv
a nasa para aprender como gerenciar
projetos internacionais com os melhores
especialistas no mundo e a singularity
university no vale do silício para
escutar e aprender com futuristas e
especialistas em inovação e
empreendedorismo e é de lá que eu trago
algumas reflexões sobre futuras
tendências
eu escutei ao vivo do peter da amams que
é um dos fundadores da assembléia disse
que o mundo se move em uma curva
exponencial que é uma curva exponencial
ninguém vai precisar que lembrar das
aulas de matemática ela funciona assim
na história da humanidade as mudanças
ocorridas de forma lenta e com a
tecnologia hoje ela ganha escala e
velocidade
as mudanças estão ocorrendo de forma tão
rápida mas porquê porque os custos dos
computadores são muito menores ea
tendência é que continue sendo reduzidos
e novas tecnologias como tecnologias
chamadas exponenciais elas transformam o
escasso e abundantes mas o que é isso na
prática
por exemplo qualquer celular desta de
seu território tem mais capacidade e é
mais rápido que o computador que o
controle do homem à lua
louco né mas é verdade
hoje usamos aplicativos para serviços na
internet que antes já fazemos de forma
física campus livros que lemos músicas
que escutamos todas as compras que
fazemos
enfim uma variedade de novas tarefas que
via computador e agora temos no bolso
há muito tempo não imprimimos mais fotos
em contrapartida hoje já podemos usar
uma impressora 3d terceira dimensão
imprimir órgãos humanos para os estudos
médicos ferramentas para indústrias até
casa estão sendo impressas para projetos
sociais
e não para por aí carros autônomos
relógios conectados ea inteligência
artificial que a tecnologia que simula a
inteligência humana também vem trazendo
novos hábitos para a sociedade
hoje quando escuta contato contactamos
com uma empresa
não sabemos se estamos falando com uma
pessoa ou um assistente virtual um robô
essas novas tecnologias elas abrem um
mar de oportunidades de convergência
para o mundo físico o mundo digital e
agora o mundo também nós humanos reikan
joel também um dos fundadores da
assembléia se respeitado futurista por
ter acertado 86% das suas previsões nos
últimos dez anos
ele diz que até 2030 nós podemos ter no
bote que são micro robozinhos nos nossos
cérebros conectados à internet que isso
poderia gerar mais inteligência mais
memória e sua tendência mas como 2030
está próximo
podemos esperar pra ver e todas essas
tendências elas também vão trazer
impactos das profissões
o relatório de professores do futuro do
fórum econômico mundial deste ano ele
prevê que 42 por cento de todo o
trabalho em horas que é feito o mundo
pode ser feito por máquinas e mais de
50% vão estar sendo feitos até 2025
como assim os robôs invadir a nossa
praia e invadiram mas cabe a nós
estarmos alerta porque vêm por aí
é como dizia a minha mãe no passado
se a gente ficar parando pra sofrer
antes da hora a gente não haja então não
adianta sofrermos temos que não ficamos
paralisados e pensar no que fazer a
revolução industrial existia já um temor
da sociedade por conta da redução dos
empregos quando foi feita a automação do
sistema fabril
houve sim o clamor da sociedade mas
novas profissões também surgiram e o que
vai acontecer agora também basta
ficarmos alerta se não queremos ser
atropelados pelo robô que andemos ao
lado dele
então ao invés de nos preocuparmos com o
que roubou vai fazer por nós temos que
nos preocupar com o que podemos
potencializar do tempo livre que vai nos
cobrar
não existe uma fórmula mágica mas eu vou
destacar aqui quatro habilidades que eu
aprendi nessa minha jornada para o
futuro
a primeira habilidade é adaptabilidade é
um exercício de desapego para
desaprender mas o que sabemos e abrimos
a nossa mente para aprender coisas novas
inclusive com os jovens eu como
profissional uma das minhas habilidades
mais forte era reduzir ao máximo a
imprevisibilidade os riscos dos meus
projetos
planejar detalhadamente mas nesse mundo
acelerado onde a gente tem que inovar ea
gente tem que fazer coisas novas muito
rápido eu tive que mudar a minha
mentalidade é aumentar a minha
capacidade de tolerar erros aceitar as
incertezas e riscos
tudo isso num ciclo de experimentar
aprender e corrigir errar voltar de
forma ágil e entregar muito mais rápido
a segunda habilidade é o pensamento
crítico mas relacionado à arte que
perguntar hoje sabemos fazer perguntas
mas quando estamos na escola somos
cobrados por responder pergunta
não necessariamente gerar perguntas que
nos levem a soluções de problemas
eu como voluntária quero muito ajudar
jovens jovens é de que não tenha a
oportunidade e que queiram realmente se
desenvolver para esse futuro ea gente
está falando aqui sabemos que é uma
invasão enorme de jovens das escolas
porque elas são atrativas mas quando
começar um projeto tem o vírus
então eu preciso perguntar entender suas
inquietudes interesses e aí sim formatar
alguma coisa pra eles e quem sabe eu
volto aqui pra contar o resultado a
terceira habilidade é a criatividade
e aí estamos falando de curiosidade
imaginação quando somos crianças somos
muito criativos mas ao longo da vida
somos tolidos às vezes até pelos nossos
próprios pais que não nos deixam por
exemplo pintar as paredes das nossas
casas com desenhos incríveis enquanto
éramos crianças
eu sei que não permitiu meu filho fazer
isso ele está ali mas já há a minha neta
com certeza vai fazer muito para aguçar
a criatividade dela e eu fico me
perguntando como vai ser a educação dela
porque ela vai ver ela vai precisar
observar muito experimentar
ela terá capacidade de imaginar e
aprender coisas novas sem medo de
levantar e cair
é isso que eu espero ea quarta
habilidade é a habilidade de comunicação
para pensar e expressar mas claramente o
nosso propósito o olho no olho a ser
ainda mais relevante num mundo tão
automatizado por exemplo olhar que eu
estou dando aqui pra vocês têm um gol
vai fazer isso só o ser humano pode
fazer inspirar e emocionar é
genuinamente uma arte humana e só
depende de nós
a minha mensagem final reforça o
d os meus pais sempre digo que o meu
filho se preparar para o futuro é
construiu agora é abrir oportunidade
para aprender e para receber é o
inesperado
qualquer um de nós pode ao invés de se
preocupar com a automação se preparar
com atividades físicas que são
efetivamente humanas aqui eu destaquei
adaptabilidade o pensamento crítico a
criatividade ea comunicação e vai
depender de cada um e é o que eu espero
pra mim ela tinha antônia e ao invés de
andar atrás do robô ela ande ao lado
dele e com certeza vai ser uma questão
única de atitude escolha dela
independente da sua cor de pele e você
escolhe
obrigado
[Aplausos]